leute was geht ab hier ist ein wachstum
herkommen zu diesem video
heute gibt es einen kleinen block
schrägstrich frage antwort video weil
ich gern noch was machen wollte und dann
so viel zeit auf katar der schulzeit
angewandt habe als überleitung und
deshalb habe ich gemeint stellt mal eure
fragen zum thema schule mit hashtags
schule max und ich merke das ist
ziemlich schwer ist die kamera die ganze
zeit so zu halten ist wird übrigens ein
relativ kurzes video heute da wir ja
noch fragen zu einem thema haben und ich
auch noch andere sachen zu tun habe
übrigens ich will nicht ganz sicher ob
das mikrofon nicht mehr stärke rochade
irgendwie hatte das zeitweise mal so ein
bisschen rum gepiepse wir sehen ob es
ihm wie ein schlag abbekommen hat oder
sonst irgendwas
ich hoffe das tut es nicht falls doch
sagen schon mal sorry lustig ist erstmal
zusehen dass sie voll viele fragen
kommen wie würdest du damals in seiner
schulzeit ich bin immer noch schüler
sehr von den lehrern erste es gab zeiten
da war ich weniger gut mit den lehrern
aber mittlerweile ist eigentlich alles
wieder einigermaßen in der reihe in
welchem fach hattest du deine
schlechteste note
ich hatte öfters mal die
schlechtestmögliche note jonas fragt
hast du viele lehrer die du hast also
ich hab eigentlich jeden lehrer den ich
habe versteht ja ja ich würde nicht
sagen dass ich irgendjemanden wirklich
hasse aber es gibt schon echt lehrer die
sind mir ein bisschen unsympathisch
herr staeck schule max was war das
heftigste was ja mal in der schule
passiert ist spontan fällt mir etwas ein
was bestimmt nicht wirklich das
heftigste war aber es war richtig cool
und zwar weil irgendwie der
getränkeautomat kaputt und ich war da an
diesem automaten wollte mir so ein cola
mix getränken weil normale cola gibt
oder gab es zwei uns nicht keine ahnung
und dann habe ich das geld eingeworfen
zwei euro drauf gedrückt das kostet
irgendwie 1 euro 10
und trotz wechsel draußen klackert so
plötzlich und dann fiel auch noch die
zwei jahren ist durch und das habe ich
dann ungefähr 15 mal gemacht habe dann
meinen klassenkameraden kostenlose
getränke gegeben und hatte zehn mal 90
cent 9 euro gemacht
gruß an den hausmeister gab es bereiche
die für geld blasen oder sonstige
sexuelle handlung durch finden der
schule das nein unity findest du physik
so benötigt das ich es ab gewählt habe
zum glück ich bin so froh dass man
manche sachen abwählen kann sonst wir
haben einen schulleben glaube ich übel
gewesen
magst was sind denn so die schulfächer
die du am meisten hasst matschie hatte
total physik mochte ja auch nicht also
dieses ganze naturwissenschaftliche zeug
ist eigentlich nicht ich bin mir sogar
sprachen typ aber mathe absolut
schlimmstes fach wirklich hört niemals
auf bei mathe hausaufgaben zu machen
oder zu üben bei mir ist das so ich
mache eigentlich gar keine hausaufgaben
und das schon vor langer also ich finde
ich ein schlechtes vorbild also ich habe
das letzte mal so wirklich hausaufgaben
gemacht in der siebten klasse oder sowas
und man kann sich das überall erlauben
also ich zumindest nur nicht bei mathe
hierbei machte keine aussage machen
nicht aufpasst seid ihr raus und dann
seid ihr wahrscheinlichste situation die
dir mal im zusammenhang mit der schule
passiert ist ich glaube hier relativ
lange ins bett gemacht und dann war ich
gleich in der dritten klasse oder so was
mal auf klassenfahrt und es kam wie es
kommen musste das war mir ziemlich
peinlich aber es hat eigentlich niemand
bemerkt weil die in die klassenlehrerin
war da schon involviert
hatte das halt irgendwie davor mit
meiner mama besprochen oder so aber es
war extrem ist ziemlich auf die frage ob
ich auch ob ich dann auf die
schultoilette gefahren ihn auch für
mädchen grundsätzlich ist ja
unkomplizierter sage ich mal als junge
aber tue ich allerdings nicht
nächste frei irgendwelche tipps damit
man sich zum lernen motivieren kann bin
leider viele kartoffeln ein absolut gar
nicht mir geht es genauso ich glaube der
wichtigste tipp ist nie damit aufzuhören
zu lernen sondern das ist einfach zur
routine werden zu lassen und ich glaube
das ist das beste
so kann man es vielleicht schaffen bis
zum abi aber ansonsten habe ich leider
keine tipps beziehungsweise klaren du
irgendwann zu viel oder zu viel im kopf
hast du nicht siehst oder so dann halt
frische luft schon raus gehen rein gehen
was trinken die stars und dann kannst du
in der regel zumindest für eine kurze
zeit so ein bisschen was schaffen wir
aber ansonsten bin ich auch echt nicht
so der lerntyp leider und welchen drei
fächern hast du die besten noten
das dürften englisch italienisch und
deutsch seien aktuell bewege ich mich
jeweils für den sehr guten guten bereich
so letzte frage findest du nicht auch
dass es in deutschland ein einheitliches
schulsystem geben sollte für alle
bundesländer
ich fand es tatsächlich sinnvoll weil
ich wohne ja in bayern und gegen bayern
zur schule und bin direkt an der grenze
zu hessen und es ist halt einfach so
ärgerlich wenn man so sieht okay die
leute die jetzt mit mir in einem
jahrgang sind in bayern gehen einfach
rüber nach hessen machen da ihr abitur
weil es einfach viel viel einfacher ist
im vergleich
ich glaube es hat sich ein bisschen
geändert in der letzten zeit aber die
leute geniale rübermachen dort drüben
ihr abitur weil es leichter ist und wir
sitzen das was ich 20 30 meter weiter
und denken uns so super und wir rackern
uns hier den arsch ab so also ich fänd's
schon cool wenn es ein bisschen
einheitlich wäre aber ich glaube es ist
auch schwer zu koordinieren weil halt
zum beispiel länder wie bayern gerne
ihre stellung hat beibehalten wollen so
von wegen
elite mäßig bla bla bla bla bla aber ja
das finde ich glaub ich ganz cool das
war es dann auch vom heutigen video
wollt ihr öfter diese themen cubase wo
ich über ein thema fragen beantwortet wo
der wollte liebsten diesem rennen ging
es für alle möglichen fragen gestellt
werden schreibt es mal die kommentare
wir sehen uns dann beim nächsten mal
wieder rund bis dahin tschüss